8:00 P.M.
SEAN HANNITY IS NEXT.
♪
>> Sean: HI, WELCOME TO
HANNITY, SO THE SCHIFF SHOW
IS BACK IN ACTION.
THE CIRCUS REMAINS IN TOWN.
TODAY, ANOTHER NATIONAL
DISGRACE.
WHAT WE SAW, AGAIN, EVERY
AMERICAN NEEDS TO SEE THIS A
B.S. PATHETIC SHOW TRIAL,
ZERO SUBSTANCE, ZERO FACTS,
ZERO -- GET, THIS FIRST-HAND
KNOWLEDGE.
NOTHING.
ZERO.
ZIP.
NADA.
AND, OF COURSE, NO DUE
PROCESS.
WE GOT A JUDGE, JURY, AND
EXECUTIONER, HIS HIGHNESS,
WE GOT THE COMPROMISED,
CORRUPT, COWARD, CONGENITAL
LIAR, ADAM SCHIFF, OH, HE
WAS IN RARE FORM TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MS. STEFANIK.
>> THANK YOU, MR. NUNES.
AMBASSADOR YOVANOVITCH,
THANK YOU.
>> THE JA GENTLE WOMAN WOULD
EXTEND.
>> WHAT IS THE INTERRUPTION
FOR THIS TIME.
>> THE GENTLE WOMAN WOULD
EXTEND.
YOU ARE NAU NOT ALLOWED TO
YIELD TIME EXCEPT FOR
MINORITY.
>> MEMBER YIELDED TIME.
>> YOU ARE GAGGING THE
GENTLE WOMAN FROM NEW YORK.
>> WILL SUSPEND NOT
RECOGNIZED.
>> THIS IS THE FIFTH TIME
HAVE YOU INTERRUPTED MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS.
>> WOMAN, NOT RECOGNIZED.
THE GENTLE WOMAN WILL
SUSPEND.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO THE
WITCH TRIAL LED BY THE
CONGENITAL LIAR.
BY THE WAY, WHAT'S HE SO
AFRAID OF?
OH, THAT'S RIGHT.
THE TRUTH.
THAT'S WHAT IS HE TERRIFIED
OF.
AND THAT'S WHY WE DIDN'T
HEAR FROM AN ACTUAL FACT
WITNESS AGAIN.
SHE KNEW NOTHING.
DEVIN NUNES SAYS WHY WAS SHE
EVEN THERE?
WE JUST GET MORE TESTIMONY,
MORE TESTIMONY, YES, ANOTHER
SELF-IMPORTANT VERY
NARCISSIST DIPLOMAT
SNOWFLAKE WHO CAN'T TAKE
MINOR, TINY BABY CRITICISM,
A WITNESS TO NOTHING.
SHE HAD NO REASON TO BE
THERE SHE WITNESSED NO
WRONGDOING, KNEW NOTHING
ABOUT WHAT WE ARE
DISCUSSING, NO DIRECT
EVIDENCE OF ANY MISCONDUCT
WHATSOEVER, NO CONTACT WITH
THE PRESIDENT, NO CONTACT
WITH HIS CHIEF OF STAFF, NO
CONTACT WITH ANYBODY THAT
REALLY KNEW THE PRESIDENT,
NO KNOWLEDGE OF ANYTHING
BEING ALLEGED BY THE
DEMOCRATS.
YOU CANNOT MAKE THIS UP.
THIS IS HOW SICK WASHINGTON
HAS BECOME.
>> WERE YOU INVOLVED IN THE
JULY 25TH TRUMP ZELENSKY
PHONE CALL OR PREPARATIONS
FOR THE CALL?
>> NO, I WAS NOT.
>> WERE YOU INVOLVED IN THE
DELIBERATIONS ABOUT THE
PAUSE IN MILITARY SALES TO
UKRAINE AS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION REVIEWED
NEWLY ELECTED PRESIDENT
ZELENSKY'S COMMITMENT TO
CORRUPTION REFORMS?
>> FOR THE DELAY.
>> FOR THE PAUSE?
>> THE PAUSE?
>> NO, I WAS NOT.
>> WERE YOU INVOLVED IN THE
PROPOSED TRUMP ZELENSKY
LATER PENCE ZELENSKY
MEETINGS IN WARSAW, POLAND
ON SEPTEMBER 1st?
>> NO, I WAS NOT.
>> DID YOU EVER TALK TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN 2019?
>> NO, I HAVE NOT.
>> MIC MULVANEY?
THANK YOU, AMBASSADOR.
>> Sean: YEAH, THEN HE SAYS
WHY THE HELL WAS SHE EVEN
THERE?
OH, AND THAT'S RIGHT, SHE
WAS FIRED HER FEELINGS WERE
HURT.
SHE HAS EXPRESSED THAT A
LOT.
AND SHE HAD A LOT OF NOT
NICE THINGS TO SAY ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
BY THE WAY, PRESIDENT OBAMA
GOT RID OF AMBASSADORS, TOO.
THIS WHOLE ENTIRE CHARADE,
NONE OF IT IS ABOUT TRUTH OR
JUSTICE.
IT IS ABOUT A NEVER ENDING
THREE-YEAR SMEAR OF THIS
PRESIDENT AT ALL COST
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT ACCEPT
THE RESULTS IN 2016.
AND AS A CONSEQUENCE, WELL,
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS, THEY
HAVE DONE NOTHING.
OH, AND GOVERNMENT FUND
SOMETHING SET TO EXPIRE NEXT
WEEK.
FUNDING FOR OUR MILITARY SET
TO EXPIRE NEXT WEEK.
AN IMPORTANT TRADE AGREEMENT
WITH CANADA AND MEXICO IS
YET TO BE APPROVED.
THESE DO NOTHING DEMOCRATS
HAVE DONE NOTHING FOR THREE
YEARS, ARE IGNORING REALLY
SERIOUS ISSUES.
LET'S SEE, PEACE AND SAFETY
AND SECURITY AND PROSPERITY
AND JOB CREATION.
WHY?
BECAUSE OF THIS PSYCHOTIC
RAGE AT THE MERE MENTION OF
DONALD TRUMP.
AND ALL AMBASSADORS, SHE
EVEN ADMITTED, THEY SERVE AT
THE PLEASURE OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
AND PRESIDENT OBAMA.
HE FIRED DOZENS OF
AMBASSADOR HOLDOVERS FROM
THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION.
AND HE DID IT FOR POLITICAL
REASONS.
NOBODY CRITICIZED HIM.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE RIGHT
TO FIRE OR HIRE ANY
AMBASSADOR FOR ANY REASON OR
NO REASON AT ALL.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THERE
WAS GOOD REASON TO WANT
TODAY'S STAR WITNESS REMOVED
FROM HER POST.
LOOK AT THESE INTERVIEWS
CONDUCTED BY JOHN SOLOMON
AND THE "NEW YORK TIMES" A
TOP UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR HAS
REPEATEDLY CLAIMED SHE GAVE
HIM A DO NOT PROSECUTE LIST
IN 2016.
NOW, THE FORMER AMBASSADOR
DENIES THE ACCUSATION.
THERE WAS ONE PAPER, I
BELIEVE, IN UKRAINE THAT
SAID HE RESCINDED THOSE
REMARKS.
WE WILL ASK JOHN SOLOMON
ABOUT IT IN A SECOND.
I DO KNOW WHO IS TELLING THE
TRUTH?
NO, I DO NOT.
HOW DOES ANY OF THIS APPLY